Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in the book of prayer
regarding the times in which it is
prohibited to pray and the exemptions
from that ruling. We mentioned there are
three main times when a person is
prohibited from praying. And what's
intended by praying
is optional prayer, additional prayer,
extra prayer, prayer that doesn't have
or is not bound by a place, a time or
occasion. And this is what we will
discuss inshallah.
Now if we were to look at optional
prayer
we would say optional prayer
can roughly be
divided into two types.
We have generally optional prayer
or what is referred to by the asl
which is just optional for no particular
time or place or occasion. It is just
optional. person feels standing and
praying before Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
well they are free to do so
and then we have the other category
which is optional prayer
which is tied to a place or time or
occasion
[Silence]
optional prayer which is tied to a time
or a place or an event or occasion.
Okay, let's give a couple of examples.
A an optional prayer. Optional meaning
it's not obligatory.
This is what we mean by optional because
you have the option of whether to use
your discretion to make it or not. If
you do not make it, you are not blamed,
right? And if you do make it, then you
are rewarded and honored for doing so.
This is what's meant by optional.
Now,
an optional prayer tied to a place.
Let's say an optional prayer tied to a
place such as
such as making the two upon entering the
masid. The majority of the view that
these two is
something which is optional and that
this is an optional prayer tied to a
place. Right? Or an optional prayer tied
to a time. An optional prayer tied to a
time are all of the optional prayers of
the five daily prayers. All of the
optional prayers that are encouraged due
to one time or another
or an optional prayer tied to an event
tied to an occasion. What is the
occasion? such as making mudoo and
making after such as
an event such as making to
upon committing a sin and wishing
to seek forgiveness from Allah
etc. anything that is tied to an
occasion or an event.
These three
optional prayer specific optional prayer
which is tied to a time, place or event
they are exempt
from the prohibition affformentioned
the prohibition of after before.
Do we understand? Now there is a
difference between
something that is tied to a place or a
time or an event or
a person
purposely
coming about one of these places or
times or events in order to pray. This
is prohibited. What do we mean by that?
Say a person knows that it's prohibited
to pray during this time. So they go to
the masid so that they have an excuse to
pray for instance. This would be
rejected. This would not be permissible.
Why? Because they are purposely trying
to get around
a ruling of Islam. It's not intended for
itself. It's intended for some other
reason.
And we will see some exceptions that
come up such as for instance the two of
of of
it is not permissible to pray after
that's the general prohibition.
A person is not to pray after once a
person makes of the obligatory that's
it. They do not pray until the sun rises
above the horizon.
However,
there is an an exemption for a person
who misses.
The prophet sallallah.aii Wasallam saw a
man praying after fud
and he asked him
you know about this and he said that he
as much
that he missed the sunnah of fud and now
he is making it up and so the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam affirmed that
he allowed him but now let's say if a
person does that every single day
every single every single day or most
days. No. Now it becomes a perversion of
the original intent
or if a person plans for that for
instance
or if a person were to purposely choose
to make
only during the prohibited times.
These things are exempt from the
exemption, right? These are exempt from
the exemptions. These are one-offs.
These are things that happen by
coincidence, as we would say. So here
the author mentions to us an exemption
from that original rule and that is a
specific type of optional prayer. What
is the specific type of optional prayer?
It is defined as an optional prayer that
is connected to a
time or place or occasion a seb right
such as
masid etc. This is tied to an occasion.
Okay. So these are exempt.
These are exempt.
The author then cites
one that is exempt due to a time and he
mentions making salah before
the im rises onto the
once the im rises onto the okay salah
now ceases. It stops.
It doesn't stop if the sun is at its
highest point at its zenith. A person is
to pray through that. Why? Because the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam made it
permissible that a person go to the
masid and pray until the imam rises onto
the meim.
Regardless of when what time that is,
whether that is before the adan of after
the adan of during the adan of whatever
that is, the person is to pray in sets
of two until the imam rises on the mimb.
This is an optional prayer which is
exempted
due to what? Which of the three?
Due to which of the three?
due to the the due to the time. due
to the time is because it's jul this is
due to the time
person may say well isn't this alak no
it's not because it's in the masid
particularly it's because it's during
jum particularly
so a person is allowed to pray until the
imam rises on the me why because of the
time the time is jar right this is the
first exemption that the author author
mentions. I just gave you three more
exemptions in my examples.
But if you walk away with nothing except
for that today, that is plenty. And that
is optional prayer which is tied
to a time or place or occasion or event.
This is exempted from the prohibitions
of prayer. Now
[Arabic recitation]
time or place or occasion
tied to the place.
This is for the masid, right? The person
enters the masid.
that is a holy sacred place. So any
prohibition of prayer while the imam is
on the mimba is exempt from that. Why?
Because it's a specific prayer that is
tied to a place which is the masjid.
Right? time,
place, occasion.
Pound it into your mind. Repeat it all
day, all night. You're picking up a bag.
You're getting in your car. You're
putting your seat belt on. You're
kissing, you know, your kids. You're
eating dinner. Whatever it is, think
about it. remind yourself so that you
can memorize these very small things
that will help you to learn and and
comprehend and digest the rulings of
[Arabic recitation]
he
I want to come up.